[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so verließ
welt was heißt eigentlich alle auf
russisch chinesisch nostro gehen solche
glaub ich bei bio ist ein schlaflied
egal jedenfalls gibt es heute russisch
brot und zwar ist es eine spezialität
ich weiß nicht ob sie das land kommt mal
ist antirussische ton mehr russische
freunde mich wirklich interessieren obst
das russische brot wirklich islam
gameswelt gibt daher kommt ja oder doch
wieder so ein marketing wahrscheinlich
naja aber jeder kennt ja diese blaue
verpackung im prinzip ist es auch im
nachgemacht video also nachgemacht große
sport- und zwar etwas süßes gebäck
richtig knusprig weil die leckeren
schoko kekse und ich muss sagen die
schmecken echtes original und also sieht
hier großes tennis macht mir hier rein
gelaufen und habe ich gedacht ein rudel
bild erzählen not luft aufs backblech
hinterlassen in buchstaben formen
buchstaben also ich find die voll lecker
und vor allem man kann sehr richtig
schnell herstellen
die zubereitung ist supereinfach und die
sind voll lange haltbar und ich dachte
ja kommen wäre dies in russland also
machen wir sogar kohle rezepte dafür
können auch wm schreiben ihr könnt so
bisschen deutschland gegen russland und
so könnte so hinlegen um nicht dass ich
glaube ich nie dabei
aber egal ob italien egal kommt bevor
wir uns jetzt noch unbeliebter machen
sage ich euch mal die zutaten die wir
nämlich dafür benötigen würden das war
zugleich die letzten jahren überhaupt
nicht wir waren nicht dabei ja und diese
weise ein kleines kind als die dabei
waren
urlaub ist auch nicht da war ich weiß
nicht was im leben das ist ja vielleicht
überraschen
für den teig brauche ich viel eiweiß
eine prise salz 150 gramm zucker etwas
von den extrakt 20 gramm kakao und 150
gramm mehl der teig ist supereinfach
hergestellt ich nehme es dann für die
küchenmaschine aber ihr könnt auch ein
handrührgerät nehmen es geht im prinzip
auch ohne aber mit dem schneebesen dauer
des steiff schlagen ein bisschen länger
und man kann da aber wir tun also es
kommt jetzt eine saubere und fettfreie
schüssel
da kommt die prise salz dazu und danke
ich das eiweiß steif schlagen
wenn das eiweiß steif ist kommt jetzt
noch der zucker lang war mit dazu und
dann rühre ich die eiweiß zucker maße
für etwa zwei minuten weiter
jetzt ist richtig schön steif und glänzt
auch schön brauche ich die maschine
nicht mehr
und jetzt kann ich mail und kaka
komischen und auch gleich dazu 7
[Musik]
und jetzt kann ich die mischung
gemeinsam mit dem wandel extrakt ganz
vorsichtig unterheben
jetzt will ich die masse in einen
spritzbeutel da vorne habe ich ein loch
ihr könnt sie aber auch ganz dünn auf
dem blech streichen im ofen backen und
später dann einfach zu schneiden aber
ich finde es immer schön aber noch nie
für sport einfach so als buchstaben da
ist und dann und da kann man doch schöne
bord bewegen uns weiter herrlich einfach
bitteschön
[Musik]
und jetzt könnt ihr einfach auf ihre
back folie ein paar buchstaben spritzen
ich habe der tiger zu bespritzen einfach
15 minuten hier stehen lassen und so
kommt das ganze jetzt in den
vorgeheizten backofen bei 170 grad ober
unterhitze und da braucht es etwa 15 bis
17 minuten
es kommt einfach darauf an wie groß die
buchstaben gespritzt sind und ich zeige
euch auch gleich einen trick woran
erkennen könnt ob die wirklich fertig
sind
wenn sich die kekse ganz einfach von der
bak folie ablösen lassen dann sind sie
fertig jetzt habe ich gelernt was hallo
heißt das video ja und tschüss
wahrscheinlich haben sich nach einer
rüge gebrauchen nachdem er ist so falsch
ausgesprochen
na ja ich würde gern nachlesen aber ich
kann keine russischen buchstaben lesen
egal jedenfalls wir sind die kekse und
ist jetzt abgekühlt und nach dem
abkühlen werden sie eben schön knusprig
jetzt darfst du gerne probieren
also ich finde die recht voll lecker
also ich weiß aus als und ist ein echtes
original aus der tüte und ich finde die
schmecken genauso dass wir im winter mal
interessieren wie dem zuschauer bewusst
so gibt es das wird in russland oder ist
ja machen schreibt uns mal
und falls ihr das rezept nach machen
möchte dann schaut auf meinem blog
vorbei auf sell off - blog.de
da steht noch mal alles ganz genau ich
wünsche euch viel spaß beim nachmachen
und wir sehen uns wieder das nächste mal
im schloss wir danke sagen hat dann beim
russisch und zwar um den berg genau wie
ich gar nicht wo dann ist ein minister
ja wo das ist ein berg
[Musik]
und danke ich das eiweiß zu einer
schnitzler
bamberg